Transcriber: Selen Yetiş
Gözden geçirme: Can Boysan
Vasiyetsiz miras.
Bu topraklardan bizlere kalan,
gelecek kuşaklara da
ne kan bağı, ne vasiyetname,
ne de başka bir unsurla kalacak miras.
Tamamen bize geçmişimizden
gelen bir miras,
vasiyetsiz miras diye tanımlıyoruz.
Bugün sizlerle birlikte,
bilim ve teknolojideki
vasiyetsiz mirasımızı konuşacağız
ve öncesinde, bilim kelimesinin
bize nereden miras kaldığına
belki de bakmamız lazım.
Bu gördüğünüz resim,
Orhun Kitabeleri'ne ait.
8. yüzyıl.
Şöyle bir sırtımızı yaslayalım,
hayal edelim.
8. yüzyıl.
Kaç yüzyıl önce ve bizlerle.
8. yüzyılda, bu kitabelerde,
bilim kelimesinin kökü olan
bilmek sözcüğü geçiyordu.
İşte bize vasiyetsiz miras kalan
geçmişimizden, bu topraklardan kalan
ve başarılarıyla bizlere örnek olmuş,
dört kişiden bugün sizlere bahsedeceğim.
Ve bu dört kişiyi bizler,
gelecek miraslara,
gelecek kuşaklara nasıl taşıyacağız?
Belki de ona hep birlikte karar vereceğiz.
Kimdir bu değerli dört kişi?
Takiyüddin, Nuri Demirağ,
Dilhan Eryurt ve Emin Bozoğlu.
Baktığımız zaman,
bugün elimizde telefonlarla,
tabletlerle, bilgisayarlarla
bir şekilde geçmişe
yolculuk yapabiliyoruz.
Artık yeni kıtaları, yeni gök bilimini
keşfetmemize gerek kalmadı.
Artık oralarda yaşayıp yaşayamayacağımıza
karar vermeye çalışıyoruz.
Yine 1500'lü yıllarda,
1570 yılında, o dönemin hükümdarına,
o dönemin padişahına, 3. Murat'a,
hocası Saadettin Efendi'nin de
bir şekilde ikna etmesiyle
İstanbul'da bir rasathane
kurulması fikri ortaya atılıyor.
Ve o dönemin, o coğrafyanın
en önemli rasathaneleri
üç tane şehirde var.
Biri Bağdat, biri Şam
ve diğeri de İstanbul.
Ve o dönemde diyorlar ki
bu rasathaneyi İstanbul'da kim yapabilir?
Tabii ki padişahın müneccimbaşı
Takiyüddin akla geliyor.
Çünkü Takiyüddin'in görevi,
gelecek ile ilgili tahminlerde bulunmak,
öngörülerde bulunmak.
Padişahtan 10 bin altın alıyor Takiyüddin
ve 10 bin altınla İstanbul'da,
güzel şehirde,
rasathane kurma çalışmalarına başlıyor.
Aynı zamanlarda,
Galata Kulesi'nin tepesine çıkıp
Galata Kulesi'nden yıldızları izleyen
bir kişi Takiyüddin.
Ve 1577 yılında, bu hayaline ulaşıyor.
Ve Takiyüddin, bu hayaliyle birlikte,
İstanbul'da rasathanesini
bizlerle buluşturuyor.
Gök bilimine olan ilgisi,
gök bilimine olan hayranlığı,
vizyonu, tutkusu,
bize, Takiyüddin'den kalan
aslında bir miras.
Diğer bir resme bakıyoruz.
Burası, Sivas-Samsun
demir yolu inşaatının fotoğrafı.
Çocukluğum da Sivas'ta geçtiği için
Sivas ile ilgili hikâyeler,
beni her zaman heyecanlandırmıştır.
Bu demir yolu inşaatını yapan
bir aile var: Nuri Bey.
Kardeşi ile birlikte
bu demir yolunun ihalesine girip,
ihaleyi alıp demir yollları macerasına
giren bir değerimiz yine Nuri Bey.
Nuri Bey, Sivas'ta
Samsun-Sivas demir yolunu
yapmaya başlamasıyla birlikte
Türkiye'nin diğer şehirlerinde de
demir yolu macerasına başlıyor.
Ve yaptığı o başarılı çalışmalarıyla,
hepimizin bildiği gibi Nuri Bey,
Demirağ soyadını alıyor.
Nuri Demirağ'ın Türkiye'ye kazandırdığı
demir yolu hattı, 1250 kilometre.
Bugün bu rakam,
Türkiye'nin en yüksek üç dağından
daha büyük bir rakam.
Ve yine bugün Türkiye'ye baktığımız zaman,
ülkemizde 12 bin kilometrelik
bir demir yolu ağı var.
Bunun 1250 kilometresini,
tek başına Nuri Bey
ve kardeşinin kurduğu ekip
ve çalışma arkadaşları yapmış.
Ama Nuri Bey'in, baktığımız zaman
başka bir özelliği daha var.
Çünkü Nuri Bey, Takiyüddin'den
devam eden bu gök bilimi aşkını
bizlere, cumhuriyet döneminde de
taşıyan insanlardan birisi.
O dönemde, ülkeler uçak yapmaya başlıyor.
Türkiye'de de diyorlar ki
o dönemin mali, ekonomik durumları,
dünyadaki konjonktürler,
Uçak almamız lazım!
Her şehirde toplanan paralarla
uçaklar alınmaya başlanıyor.
Her alınan şehrin uçağının kanadına da
kuyruk tarafına da o ilin ismi veriliyor.
Ve hem şehirden toplanan bağışlar,
halkın topladığı bağışlar,
hem de iş adamlarının
topladığı bağışlara göre,
uçaklar alınmaya başlarken,
Nuri Demirağ'a da gidiliyor.
Nuri Demirağ diyor ki: Ben kendim
uçak yapmak istiyorum.
Niye bağış yapıp da bir uçak satın alayım.
Ve işte o hayalini
gerçekleştirmeye çalışıyor.
Takiyüddin'den bize kalan miras, azimdi.
Nuri Demirağ'dan ise
bize kalan miras, mücadeledir.
Çünkü Nuri Demirağ, bu hayalini
mücadelesi ile süsleyerek
bugün, o güne baktığımız zaman,
bugün de yapmaya çalıştığımız hayalleri
otuzlu yıllarda, kırklı yıllarda
hayata geçiriyor.
Türk Hava Kurumu'nun 65 planör
ve 25 eğitim uçağı siparişini
teslim ediyor Nuri Demirağ ve ekibi.
Ve Nu.D-38 uçağı, 6 adet üretilen
ve 6 kişilik bir yolcu kapasitesine sahip
250 kilometre hıza çıkıp, 5500 metreye
yükselebilen bir yolcu uçağını da
Nuri Demirağ, dünyaya kazandırıyor.
Tabii sadece uçak yapmıyor.
O kadar önemli işler var ki arkada,
baktığımız zaman.
Çünkü bir gök okulu kuruyor.
Bugün Beşiktaş'ta bulunan deniz müzesi,
gidenlerimiz mutlaka bilir
çok güzel bir yerde.
O dönemde, ilk başta
Sivas'ta kurmak istiyor.
Fakat daha sonra, fabrikasını
bu deniz müzesinin orada kuruyor.
Daha sonra Atatürk Havalimanı'nın
bulunduğu Yeşilköy'de
bir gök okulu kuruyor.
Ve geçtiğimiz 2011 yılında kaybettik,
Mehmet Bey.
O dönemin ilk mezunlarından bir pilot.
Ve en yaşlı pilot olarak hayata gözlerini,
o zaman da Türkiye'nin
ilk pilotlarından biri olarak
yummuştu Mehmet Bey.
Ve o da yine Nuri Demirağ'ın
bu gök okulundan mezun oldu.
Biz, vasiyetsiz mirasımız olarak,
Nuri Demirağ'dan
aldığımız miras, mücadeleydi.
Ve o mücadele ile bu
başarının nasıl yapılabileceğini,
o dönemlerde bize Nuri Demirağ,
arkadaşları, ekibi gösterdi.
Bizler için gerçekten bu çok kıymetliydi.
Bu gördüğümüz resim, Emin Bey.
Emin Bey, Türkiye Cumhuriyeti Devlet
Demir yolları Genel Müdür Yardımcısı.
Tarih, 16 Haziran 1961.
CAR atölyesindeki mühendislerle beraber,
kendi ekibiyle 20 kişilik
bir toplantı yapıyor.
Toplantıya davet ettiği arkadaşlarına,
mühendislerine, dostlarına
söylediği cümle şu:
"Elimde bir mektup var.
Bu mektup, bizden,
Türkiye'nin ilk otomobilini
yapma arzusu olan bir mektup.
Ve bizim, Cumhuriyet Bayramı'na, 29 Ekim'e
bu otomobili yetiştirmemiz lazım." diyor.
6 ay kadar bir süre var.
Hikâyeyi zaten bilenleriniz bilir.
O dönemde, Eskişehir'de,
Eskişehir'deki tren atölyelerinde,
fabrikalarında
bu araba yapılmaya başlandı.
İnanılmaz bir hikâye.
Yani, bugün bizlere
film gibi gelecek bir hikâye.
Filmi de çekildi.
Ama biraz hayal edelim,
nasıl bir mücadele, nasıl bir inanç,
nasıl bir tutku, nasıl bir azim
ve işte yine bizim vasiyetsiz mirasımız.
Ve baktığımız zaman 6 aylık bir sürede,
6 aylık bir çalışmada,
tamamen kendi imkanlarıyla,
küçük bütçelerle yapılan üretimle,
bizim tarihimizde, bu gördüğümüz,
devrim arabaları geliyor.
Fakat o kadar enteresandır ki
aslında, son gün arabalardan biri bitiyor.
Diğerinin de pasta cilası,
Eskişehir'den Ankara'ya,
törenlere yetiştirilmek üzereyken,
trende atılıyor.
Ve o zaman tabii trenlerin teknolojisi
şimdiki gibi değil.
O zamanki trenlerde götürürken, aman
kıvılcımlardan arabaya bir şey gelir,
yangın çıkar, araba hasar görür diye,
arabaya benzin konulmuyor.
Araba Ankara'ya vardığında
polis eskortları,
tabii ki benzin konulup konulmadığı
iletişimini kurmadıklarından dolayı,
arabaya, ilk o dönemin
cumhurbaşkanı bindiğinde
100 metre sonra iki numaralı araba
maalesef yolda kalıyor.
Fakat ertesi gün basında,
medyada, kamuoyunda haberler:
"Devrim Arabaları Yolda Kaldı".
Halbuki hikâye bu değil.
O dönemin Cumhurbaşkanı
Cemal Gürsel iniyor,
diğer arabaya biniyor
ve diğer arabayla önce meclise,
sonra Anıtkabir'e
ve tören alanına gidiyor.
Aslında araba çalışıyor.
Diğer arabayı kullanıyorlar.
İşte bize Emin Bey'den, Emin Bey'in
ekibinden kalan harika bir hikâye var.
Çünkü o dönemde, 60'lı yıllarda
bu araba yapıldı.
Vazgeçilmeseydi, belki devam edilseydi,
çok farklı bir dünyada,
Devrim Arabaları'nın hikâyesini
sadece bizler değil,
tüm dünya bilmiş olacaktı.
Bize, o dönemden kalan vasiyetsiz miras,
Emin Beyler'den, Emin Bozoğlu
ve ekibinden kalan vasiyetsiz miras,
tutkudur, inanmaktır.
Çünkü bu coğrafyada, bu topraklarda,
bu iki kelime, tutku ve inanmak,
bizler için çok kıymetli kelimeler ki
biz bu mirası önümüzdeki dönemlere,
önümüzdeki kuşaklara taşıyabilelim.
20 Temmuz 1969.
Baktığımız zaman,
Ay'a insanoğlu ayak bastı.
Önemli bir tarih.
Şimdi biz, bu dönemlerde,
en azından benim kuşağım,
internetten, televizyonlardan izledik.
Ama o dönemde yaşayanlar için
muazzam bir olay.
İnsanoğlu Ay'ı keşfediyor
ve Ay'a ayak basıyor.
Fakat biliyor muyuz, yine o
ayak basan ekibe destek olan,
o ayak basan ekipte yer alan
bir Türk kadın bilim insanı var.
İşte bu da bizim bir vasiyetsiz mirasımız.
Sevgili Dilhan Eryurt var.
Dilhan Eryurt,
çocukluğundan beri astronomiye,
matematiğe ilgi duyuyor.
İstanbul'da astronomi
ve matematik eğitimini alıyor.
Daha sonra yaptığı çalışmalarla,
yurt dışında farklı eğitimler,
farklı projelerde yer alıyor.
Kanada'da Atom Enerjisi Kurumu'na gidiyor.
Daha sonra orada tanıştığı
Profesör Cameron ile,
farklı projelerde yer alıyor.
Ama en önemlisi, Güneş'in ilk zamanları
ile ilgili bir tespit yapıyorlar.
Bilinen bilimsel gerçekte
Güneş'in önce soğumaya başladığı
ve bugüne o şekilde geldiği söyleniyordu.
Ama Dilhan Hanım ve Profesör Cameron,
bunun tam tersi olduğu
bir bilimsel gerçekle karşıya çıkıyorlar.
Ve Ay'a gidiş,
o dönemde bu gerçekten dolayı,
bu bilgiden dolayı, zamanlaması
biraz daha öteleniyor.
Belki bu bilgi olmasaydı
çünkü bilgi en büyük güç.
Ay'a insanoğlu ayak basamayacaktı
ya da daha geç basacaktı.
Çünkü Güneş'in ısınması,
Ay'a giden uzay aracı için
çok kritik bir bilgi.
Ve Dilhan Hanım'a, o dönemde,
yaptığı bu çalışmadan dolayı,
NASA tarafından, Apollo ödülü veriliyor.
Ve bunu, o dönemlerde
başaran bir Türk kadını,
bir Türk bilim insanı.
İşte, Dilhan Hanım'dan,
Dilhan Eryurt'tan bizim alacağımız miras,
tabii ki astronomiye olan ilgi,
tabii ki uzaya olan ilgi,
tabii ki o dönemde yapılmış bir başarı
ama en büyük vasiyetsiz mirası,
bize Dilhan Hanım'ın, inanmaktı.
Ve Türk kadınının, Türk insanının,
isterse tarihe nasıl geçeceğini
kanıtlamasıydı.
Bu bizim için çok kıymetliydi,
çok değerliydi.
Ve bu dört kişiden
bizim aldığımız bu mirası,
mutlaka bir sonraki kuşaklara,
bir sonraki dönemlere,
tutkuyla, azimle, mücadeleyle, başarıyla,
taşımamız gerekiyor.
Çünkü bizim geçmişimizde,
tarihimizde işte bu miras var,
bu başarılar var.
Bu başarıları bilmemiz gerekiyor.
Bu başarıları sonraki kuşaklara
aktarmamız gerekiyor.
Atlar, tarihimize baktığımızda
bizler için çok kıymetli atlar.
Çünkü Orta Asya'dan beri,
at sırtında olan bir toplumuz, milletiz.
Bilim ve teknoloji,
işte bu at sırtında gelen insanlarla
bizim bu coğrafyamıza geldi.
Bugün bu arkada çalan eser de
Sultan Abdülaziz'in Gondol eseri.
Avusturya ziyaretinde,
Avusturya Kraliçesi'ne sunduğu
kendi bestesi.
Baktığımız zaman,
atlar özgürlüklerine çok düşkündür.
Özellikle kamyonlarda giderken,
bilenler bilir,
atların arabalarında bir açıklık vardır.
Normalde, atların arkası
oraya dönük olarak,
güvenlik olarak gitmesi gerekirken,
atlar yüzlerini dönerler.
Çünkü ufka bakmayı,
özgürlüğü seven hayvanlardır.
Atlar, sosyal hayvanlardır.
Kesinlikle yalnız kalmak istemezler.
Ondan dolayı,
insanlarla çok güçlü bağlar kurarlar.
Ve bizim tarihimizde,
önemli bir hayvandır atlar.
Ve işte atlardan bize kalan, atlarla
birlikte düşünebileceğimiz birliktelik.
Biz, bizim için çok önemli kavramlar.
Eğer biz, birlik olmaya, birlikte
bir şeyler yapabileceğimize,
önümüzdeki kuşakları inandırabilirsek,
önümüzdeki kuşaklara, gençlere
bu hayalleri kurdurabilirsek,
işte o zaman, vasiyetsiz mirasımıza
nasıl sahip çıktığımızı
hep birlikte görmüş olacağız.
Çok teşekkür ediyorum.
Sağ olun.
(Alkış)